but if you're trying to get something
that's memorable because it meant
something you've got to earn it you got
to give us those breadcrumbs you got to
set up that other stuff so we can know
why this moment matters
seen and how does scene Advance a story
yeah so we're going to look at each
scene like many movies right each of
them has a goal each scene connected to
the next scene is what gonna is what's
going to get your character to reach
their larger goal and so if you're going
through your screenplay
and you realize you've got a scene with
no purpose then that's where you can cut
right so going back to revising or
rewriting or second drafts Etc if you
have a scene that has no purpose and is
not pushing the story forward because
it's not reaching a mini goal that's
going to get us to the larger goal then
you know that that's a place where you
can cut
how does a scene build tension and
conflict yeah so going back to that goal
right it needs to have the goal of doing
that
um but if you know what they're trying
to accomplish then you know how you can
complicate it in this particular scene
and that complication can be the thing
that builds the tension so you can do
that in many different kinds of ways but
like let's say for example uh going back
to the girl and her mother and the girl
is upset with her mother so we already
know that there's tension there because
we already know that they're upset so
how are you going to show me in this
scene where it's going to take us
through the rest of it because it's not
about the scene existing on its own so
we've built the tension by showing that
they're upset with each other maybe
they're in the middle in the middle of
an argument maybe she does get to curse
her out maybe she only just runs out and
slams the door right so maybe the goal
of that scene was to establish that they
don't have a good relationship but then
this scene can't stand on its own so how
does this information now transfer into
into the rest of the film how does it
affect the next scene which then affects
the next scene and the next scene so
that we can get to wherever it is we're
trying to get them to go and let's say
if our overall goal is to get them to
um CII or have dealt with their with
their problems obviously they won't
disappear as 2023 so it won't be magical
and all of a sudden we love each other
you know whatever but they will have
gotten to a place of understanding then
now we're trying to figure out how that
tension gets us there
um another way that you can build
tension is if the audience knows
something that the characters don't know
so maybe we know what's up what's what's
uh the issue for the young ladies that
she just found out that her mom is
dating someone again so she feels like
you always choose men over me but she
doesn't have the vocabulary for that so
instead she's cussing at her and running
out of the room and slamming the door
the tension is not only Built from the
fact that they're in Conflict but it's
also because we know why she's mad and
mom doesn't know why she's mad so
they're all different kinds of ways to
build that tension but even on top of
building the tension you want to ask
yourself where it's going to go we need
the tension because it's going to be a
trajectory for whatever is coming next
in the screenplay
process of visualizing a scene
and then writing it in a way that's
engaging and cinematic yeah so I would
look at
um building your scenes like you build
the entire screenplay so it's going to
start in your outline and it's going to
start with knowing what it takes to get
your character to reach their goal or
solve their problem right so if I know
that it's going to take
therapy more fights or whatever for our
daughter and mother to get to a place of
understanding each other then now I have
to plot out those scenes that get us
there
um and so if you're a visual person then
you might ask yourself
um well what kind of therapy setting is
best for these two characters they're
already explosive when we meet them
they're explosive so the way that I
build this Therapy Center or this
therapist office or this grandmother or
whoever it is that they're going to end
up going to to talk to that may be a
place where I get to add something
different to the world that's a little
bit more engaging and can break up the
monotony of these two people yelling at
each other right because if we've been
seeing them do that up until now then
we're going to have to shake things up a
little bit and so asking yourself what
the world of that therapy office looks
like
um uh I'm not a person who who needs to
who needs to visualize it in the way of
needing a mood board for it right but
some people are that way so what does
the couch look like what does the desk
look like are they in there together do
they go separately
um what kind of therapists do they need
right um do they need someone who's
direct do they need someone who's more
soft do they need blah blah blah and the
more you know about all three of those
characters because they're probably
going to spend a lot of time together
since we've decided that therapy is
going to be the thing that gets them to
their breaking point then we need to
figure out how these people are going to
interact with each other because a lot
of our engagement is going to come from
that so really understanding and even
going back to if they're going to be in
therapy for half of the film then that
can get monotonous too so you have to
ask yourself what goals are they
reaching in these therapy scenes what
gets them to a place where we can pull
out of it because maybe it's not working
anymore maybe one of them is giving up
or maybe they think they've made it to
an impasse and they don't want to go to
therapy anymore what ever it is figuring
out how you're going to break up that
monotony but you can only do that if you
know where you need them to go and if
you really understand each of the
characters because they're going to make
moves based on who they already are so
all of that builds the scene right so
you can't take the scene in my opinion
uh
as an individual thing as if it doesn't
exist with everything else you got to
figure out how
um it affects everything else and that
being engaging part is going to be in
your dialogue in your action and how
they uh work through things and how they
don't work through things and how they
interact with each other and that's the
stuff that's going to make it
interesting or like we said before if
you know that these two these two are
you know always on Ten and then they end
up getting a therapist who lives on two
then that's going to give you you know
it's going to already give you something
cool and different to deal with in those
scenes or they have a therapist that
eventually sides with the other and now
the other one storms out of the office
and slams the door now they hate the the
other and the therapist and the
therapist right and so now it's changed
the story a little bit because if I also
hate the therapist and I hate the person
who is supposed to you know do the work
and help me to get through this and so
now we got to figure out where the story
is going to go from that and does that
mean that the therapist is going to have
to win the trust back does that mean
they're going to go you know not go to
therapy anymore try to get a new
therapist what is it going to do so all
of it's going to affect the you know the
next thing
what can a writer do to make scenes more
memorable Make Scenes more memorable hmm
that's that's the hard part I think you
know sometimes I watch movies and I
don't come out of it remembering
anything right but I think good dialogue
will do that
good tension will do that good special
moments we'll do that like the um the
movie of course that I can't think of
the name of but the the one about the
Cowboys on Netflix like that moment when
that little boy finally got the courage
because we could tell that he felt well
the the premise is he doesn't know his
father
I grew up in a different city with his
mom and you know his dad had been in
jail for most of his life and maybe he'd
been out for however long but again they
didn't live in the same area so they
didn't have a relationship well he's an
older boy now he's a teenager mom thinks
you need to go be with your dad but
here's a guy I don't know here's a guy
who I think didn't choose me didn't want
me here's a guy who has a relationship
with all of these other Cowboys but
doesn't have one with me and we can see
that throughout scene by scene scene by
saying so when he finally gets the
courage to say why don't you love me
we've already started in a memorable
scene but that had to be earned if he
would have said that on day one it's not
memorable you know what I mean like I
needed all of the conflict all the
complications all of the tension before
that scene in order for me to get to a
place where it's memorable
or let's take something that people know
really well and let's take Dirty Dancing
right that dance lift
is not memorable just because it's a
dance lift right so if you look at a
movie like you got served they're
dancing all through the thing you know
like who's paying attention to one dance
move versus the other but in uh in Dirty
Dancing this lift matters because we see
how hard they worked on it we know
they're not supposed to be working you
know together in the first place because
she's from a different you know a
different
um uh she's more affluent I guess you
can say than he would be considering and
they're probably the dad wouldn't accept
him and things like this things like
that and it's dirty dancing so she
shouldn't be doing this anyway she
couldn't dance in the first place right
so she had to learn just how to do the
dances period let alone be really good
at it right so we have all of that
information so when we get to the end
and he turns to her and he's like you
can do it it's already a memorable scene
right because we had to earn getting
there so maybe the answer is you got to
earn a memorable scene they're not going
to be memorable just on their own you
can do something great you can do
something and funny you know if you if
you think about a comedy like coming to
America there's all kind of memorable
scenes because they're funny right
um whether they're earned or not right
you know but they're funny but if you're
trying to get something that's memorable
because it meant something you've got to
earn it you got to give us those
breadcrumbs you got to set up that other
stuff so we can know why this moment
matters